hello and welcome to the pledge Theresa
May may be hanging on but a voice
certainly isn't mr. speaker mr. speaker
I beg to move okay you may say that when
you should hear jump toward Yonkers
voice as a result
[Applause]
last time her voice was this cranky she
was and some MPs couldn't resist making
jokes in the Commons about the Prime
Minister's lack of voice making a cheap
joke at the expense of someone else we
at the pledge would never sink so low
coming up
Majid says we need to stop playing
politics with kids lives a fwah thinks
it's time for is bride Shamima to come
home
Michele calls for kindness and Rachel
asks who rules the world but first it's
me at times you had to wonder which
tourism a would lose first her voice or
her job at the time of recording she
appears to have hung on to both but what
has been undoubtedly and unceremoniously
shredded however is the PM's Authority
unable even to whip her own cabinet and
what does that say about her power she
agreed to a free vote over the future of
the No Deal option
she was also inexplicably still clinging
to the ludicrous delusion that life
could be breathed into the deal that's
proved as popular as a dose of herpes
indeed is earned her two of the four
biggest defeats ever in parliamentary
history now her deal is defeated No Deal
discarded and a delay demanded but it is
an inconvenient truth for many in
Westminster that while the referendum
showed the majority of the electorate
want to leave the EU many of our
parliamentarians do not so they've been
granted their extension now they need to
sort it and faster than I don't know a
Ferrari lots ton pack fair hmm and my
guess is no better than yours Nik I mean
I think that now we have an extension
you know I can quite imagine that you
know in many decades to come we will be
knowing on roast rat in our shelters and
Theresa May will so be putting her
meaningful vote to Parliament again and
again as we carry on she's gonna still
be Prime Minister
she seems indestructible although
everything is detonating around her
there she is with her tunes yeah ready
to carry on and I think what's gonna
happen is this you've got to see this in
terms of a four horse race there and
some four horse race you know you've got
No Deal is still there because if we
don't get her result on her deal then
the legal parameters dictate that we
have to leave the EU on the 29th we have
her deal which as I think she's going to
keep putting it as many times as she
needs Wednesday she's going to put her
deal I don't think that she's gonna win
but she's winning she's losing by less
as he each time general election and
then we have referendum and if you see
it in terms of Cheltenham races where I
may be going name the bookmakers on gone
general election and referendum are
nosing faster than they were no deal and
her deal are receding in the field magic
well you see the thing is I feel like
what with Breck see I feel like we're in
a taxi a families jumped into this tax
and the head of the family man or woman
doesn't matter for this analogy is said
to the driver drive and the poor taxi
drivers flipped the meter on and he says
alright I've no where do you want me to
go to it doesn't matter just drive and I
feel like the frustration that so he
starts moving the car he's heading
towards an airport he's got all the bags
in the back and he says which airport
you want me to drive to Gatwick Heathrow
Stansted you know South End in Essex is
quite good these days by the way there's
an airport and he's and and the
passengers say we don't care just drive
you know and this is the problem we
don't know where we're headed the EU has
to agree to an extension that we've
achieved and they will want to know
where the destination is I think before
we they dredge this destined to this
exact we've got to get let them know
what it is they might say we need to
know what you want and if you don't know
what you want the rider to granting this
extension is we need a confirmation from
a tree referendum yeah well this is just
the point it's very quickly this was the
point of what I was trying to say that
leave me means leave doesn't help us
understand a where we want to go and be
what the EU needs to know to actually
agree to this extension right let's get
spare to save this panel you're probably
the most ardent lever I would say of the
I mean I'm a reluctantly be you're
really believe do you think you're
closer to your goal no I mean I was
probably not too dissimilar to you I
don't wake up I don't wake up in the
morning chanting bricks it breaks it
breaks it nor do I hang out in the rear
and you know chanting it either so
absolutely on balance I wanted bricks
there and I'm very disappointed I've
said this throughout brexit could and
should have been managed very very
differently and as a matter of
comparison all our difference I was at
Churchill's war rooms a couple of days
ago and watching the bunker spirit of
cross-party working and people coming
together and him showing true leadership
obviously a very different scenario but
we have been let down as the virtus we
haven't had true leadership people are
very confused as to where we are I think
I know where we are now I'm got herpes
I'm in a taxi again the House of Commons
says what it doesn't want now this
impasse can only be sold in the UK so
they're backing it back to us and my
final point is I was so disappointed
that the No Deal option I know it wasn't
legally binding or anything but I was so
disappointed that people voted to take
that off the table because I do not
understand how anyone could consider
having a basic even a basic no matter
complex negotiation if you take that
opportunity to walk with off the table
it's just backwards that's good I want
to bring you just reflect on this if you
would the Prime Minister you use someone
who three years ago Michael Gove was
booted out of the cabinet now he is her
voice in the House of Commons disgust is
incredible everything has shifted to a
surreal degree I mean you think about
Faraj then and now I think about Michael
Gove then and now you've got the
Attorney General who's not usually known
for moments of high drama by the way I
think sounding what was actually the
death knell for this withdrawal
agreement this week let's just have a
listen to what Jeffrey Cox said in the
comments let me make it clear the legal
risk as I set it out in my letter of the
13th of November remains unchanged I
just want to pick up on what you said
Michelle because this all comes together
for me the reason that the House voted
to take no deal off the table is because
it was on the table for almost two years
we have failed to get a withdrawal
agreement that's acceptable to brexit
ears and I feel that brexit ears are
going to rewrite history to say it was
remain people who have messed up our
chances of leaving on 20 like month
please let's remember they voted against
this deal they hate this deal and they
did not want to see it happen so it's
not just these supposedly who remain
people trying to be better than a bad
deal but nobody wants our know Dylan you
have people like Philip Hammond talking
about the international reputation of
damage that's been done to our country
by the complete calamity of leaving no
deal on this point of brexit is okay so
no series of tweets on earth was direct
point just there if you if you have a
look at them he says as brexit ears tuck
into their porridge this morning they
have a very difficult decision to make I
hope they won't mind some frank advice
for one who is a colleague to all and at
friends are some do yourselves a favor
take the win vote for the deal he then
went on and said if you don't people
like me will conclude that you'll never
be satisfied that you aren't open to
compromise that you are hell-bent on
forcing the UK to crash out of the EU
without a deal we will then do whatever
it takes to frustrate you we will vote
to stop No Deal brexit on the 29th of
March we will vote to extend article 50
for a few months and we will then work
with opposition parties to build a
majority for a softer proxy deal okay
let's get Rachel back yes I just we need
to return to the Attorney General and
you know everybody was waiting for him
to say you have a sort of give us a
means the ladder for the ERG to climb
down so they could vote for the brexit
they so desire yet
what we saw was political will being
destroyed on the anvil of legality and
so Jeffrey Cox as we all know came back
and said that there was no unilateral
exit from the backstop and then John
snow tweeted a lawyer contact tells me
that the legal word is aware that the
Attorney General said no last night to
the validity of mrs. maids new EU deal
he's been told to go away and find a way
to say yes this is John snows tweet a
cohort of lawyers has been summoned
Jeffrey Cox replied with one word
everyone fortunate language I would
suggest Jacob Riis MOG was asked this
week or indicated in other week that in
fact he's lost brexit because of the
action taken be it by the Arg his
effectively effectively kiss goodbye do
you think brexit will happen I think it
probably will happen but as Jacob Riis
MOG points out himself
the majority of MPs don't want it to
happen so we this is why we are in this
logjam they cannot execute that's not
democracy is it well why is it democracy
it's that you can put Tereza males maze
deal to Parliament three times but you
can't ask the people twice magic
increasingly no unlikely but I don't
know what the alternative would be at
this stage because I don't even know
what I don't know if there's enough time
for people's vote at this stage I know
she said revoke yes revoke it altogether
but so it's so on that note whatever
path we take will always be a minority
path at this stage there isn't a
majority for any one path and in that in
that context aren't we then all obliged
to follow our conscience Michelle
will we break sit before you recover
from herpes it's a lifelong disease so
I've had well I mean that is the
million-dollar question isn't it and how
long is this extension gonna happen so
can we revoke article 50 no yes we can
no no she hasn't
yes we can should we absolutely not it
would be catastrophic and very quickly
to your final point
WTO taken off the table if it would be
so catastrophic it would also then be
some level of catastrophic to the EU
which is all a more reason why it should
have been left on the table so that
people could negotiate properly so to
avoid it if that is if that is such a
surefire strategy why has it failed
until now when you understand wait days
away from the original date we are not
going to yes or no yes or no yes or no
yeah okay I'm out of time Majid